[Auto-generated transcript. Edits may have been applied for clarity.]
אני מקווה. טוב, זה לא כזה נורא זמן.
תשובה זוגית. אפשר.
טוב, אני לא כל כך יודע למה זה רק על המסך שלי.
טוב. אז.
בפעם הקודמת בעצם סיימנו את הדיון שלנו.
בהגדרה של מילים. כן, דיברנו על זה שהמושג מילה אוקיי.
שהמושג מילה הוא בעצם מושג שדורש איזשהו דיון.
היו כל מיני הצעות בספרות בספרות הבלשנית לאורך השנים, אבל כל אחת עם הבעיות שלה,
ובסופו של דבר דיברנו על זה שנהוג כיום להבחין בין שני סוגים של מילים שבעצם משקפים שתי פרספקטיבות שונות שעשויות להביא להוביל לפרידה קצוות מנוגדות,
שעשויות להוביל למסקנות שונות לגבי הדרך לנתח את המילה.
אבל שתיהן, וליתר דיוק כן אחת מהם, וזאת שפחות נפוצה בהקשר של ניתוח טקסט, אבל מטבע הדברים היא מאוד נוכחת.
כשאנחנו מדברים על ניתוח של speech speech.
בסיס זה בעצם גישה שמסתכלת בעיקר על פיצ'רים פונולוגית, מה שנקרא פיצ'רים צלילים פחות או כמעט בכלל לא התעסקנו בזה בקורס הזה, אבל בגדול מסתכלת על דברים.
כמו כן, מתי משתהים?
כן, מתי יש שקט. מסתכלים על מבנה הברות של מילה, על מאפיינים פרו סודיים.
כן, כלומר הניגון של מילה. כן, האינטונציה כן.
איפה מדגישים התאמה? כן מלעיל מהירה וכן הלאה וכן הלאה.
כלומר מדברים על בעצם פיצ'רים צלילים של מילה.
בעוד שהגישה השנייה, שהיא היותר דומיננטית Map, מסתכלת על מה שנקרא גורמת Words, כלומר לא מסתכלת על,
לא מסתכלת על מילים ועל הגדרה של מילים דרך הפריזמה של הצלילים שלהם או של אות של סיגנל הדיבור,
אלא מסתכלת על מילים בתור יחידות שמשתתפות במבנה תחבירי במבנה דקדוקי או שעוברות הטיות.
כן, הטיות כמו למשל ואנחנו תכף נראה דוגמאות.
כן הפיקסיז Season, כלומר הוספה של מוספיות כן, כמו הקטניות.
נכון, אני יכול להגיד מטבח או מטבחון או קטן או קטנטן.
כן, וזה לכל מיני תהליכים באופן לוגי אחד זה הפיקציה.
הוספה של הוספת בסוף השנייה זה הכפלה. כן, מה שנקרא כאן וידאו application כן ואולי shift של כל מיני שינויים שאולי אתם עוד זוכרים מלימודי הלשון שלכם.
ואם לא כל כך קריטי של כן, שקשורים לכל מיני תהליכים של תנועות שהופכות לתנועות אחרות כשהם.
במסגרת במסגרת נטייה של מילה, אז כל הדברים האלה הם בעצם יהיו התופעות שיגדירו גם את זה.
אבל ההגדרה הזאת עדיין לא עדיין נותנת לנו הגדרה ברורה מה זה אומר או מתי ראוי שנפרד בין מילים.
כן? מתי ראוי שנגיד שמשהו שכתוב בין שני רווחים הוא בעצם כמה תוכן זה או כמה כמה מילים על השם הטכני יהיה תוכן.
אז מסיבות שאנחנו נראה בהמשך הקורס כן, אבל.
אבל בעצם על ההגדרה הקודמת עדיין נותנת לנו סכמה.
כן, עדיין נותנת לנו כללים ברורים מתי אנחנו צריכים לפצל ומתי לא, ובשביל זה צריך קצת להיכנס לתחום שאנחנו כמעט לא נדון בו בקורס הזה.
אולי במסגרת, אם נשאר לי עוד שיעור בסוף, שזה מה שנקרא מורפולוגיה.
אוקיי, אז מורפולוגיה זה תורת הצורות.
זה בעצם תחום בדקדוק שעוסק במבנה של מילים.
כן, במבנה הפנימי של מילים, כלומר לא איך מילים מתחברות יחד כדי לייצר משפט רכיב טקסט, אלא המבנה הפנימי של מילים.
יש שפות שאין בו, שאין בהן כמעט בכלל מורפולוגיה.
יש שפות שיש בהם מורפולוגיה מאוד עשירה כמו עברית או ערבית.
לדוגמן שבא יש משקלים ובניינים ושורשים והוא סופיות, סופיות וכליות והרבה הרבה דברים שונים.
ויש שפות עם לוגיות מסוגים אחרים שגם הם מאוד עשירות.
ובדרך כלל כשאנחנו מדברים ככה גרוס מודו. כן, אנחנו מדברים על ניתוח מורפולוגי NLP.
אנחנו מתכוונים לחלוקה של מילה לחתיכות ותיאור של המבנה שמרכיב אותם ביחד, כן של המבנה שבו הם נמצאות.
תכף נראה כמה דוגמאות לזה, אבל.
מה שחשוב לדעת זה שהבחירה של סכמה מסוימת לניתוח מורפולוגי היא במידה רבה בחירה שרירותית.
אוקיי, כלומר חלוקה מורפולוגית.
הניתוח מורפולוגי הוא בהחלט מושפע על ידי תובנות שמגיעות מתיאוריות פולשניות שונות
שמגיעות כן לפעמים מכל מיני שיקולים פרקטיים או שיקולים של עקביות בין שפות בניתוח.
אבל בסופו של דבר יש הרבה מאוד דרגות חופש, אפילו אחרי שלוקחים את כל הדברים האלה בחשבון, וברגע שאתם מגיעים לאיזשהו לאיזשהו טקסט,
לאיזשהו קורפוס, שמישהו כבר איבד אותו מהמצב הגולמי שהוא נמצא בו, לא דפי Web למשהו קצת יותר מסודר.
בדרך כלל יש איזושהי סכמה שהם שמפנים אליה איזושהי הסכמה לניתוח מורפולוגי שבאמצעותה הם ביצעו את האנליזה,
וקורסים שונים בהחלט עשויים להוביל ניתוחים שונים.
אז אוקיי, אז אז מה? בגדול אנחנו רואים. אז אני חושב, כנראה אחד הניתוחים הבסיסיים ביותר שאתם תמצאו.
אני חושב בהרבה מאוד קורסים, כנראה ברובם, שאתם פשוט נתקלים בהם.
זה מה שנקרא תו כניסה חציה כן, שאותו כניסה ציון. מה שזה אומר זה לחלק.
לפעמים זה לא בדיוק לחלק אבל. אבל בדרך כלל זה לחלק את המילה או את הטקסט לחתיכות שכל אחת מהן ממילה או חתיכה
ממילה בלי יותר מדי להתעכב על איך בדיוק הם מחוברות יחד כן או מה כל חלק אומר,
האם זה הקטנה או יחיד או רבים, או הטייה לזמן עבר או לזמן עתיד אלה פשוט לחלק דברים לחתיכות שנקראים תוקף, ולכן זה נקרא תוקף נזקיה.
באנגלית בדרך כלל הרמה המינימלית והאמת גם די מקובלת.
זה תכלס להפריד רק את הדברים שיש בהם הפוסט דרופינג.
אני לא יודע למה, אבל זה כבר די נפוץ. למה אני מתכוון? כל כן הגרש העליון הזה אתם מכירים?
כן כמו באינטרנט אז isn't יהפוך ל is ואנט כן או עם יהפוך לאיי וגרש ולט יהפוך לכם וזה וכנל כינויי שייכות.
אבל במקרים שבהם אין את הגרש הזה פשוט לא יפרקו.
גם אם זאת הטייה בכל מובן אחר מאוד דומה.
גם כן, גם אם זה מילה מאוד ארוכה, לרוב באנגלית, מסכם אותה טיפוסיות.
לא התעסקו בזה יותר מדי. הסיבה שלא התעסקו בזה יותר מדי זה אנחנו.
נגיע לזה קצת בהמשך הקורס, אבל בגדול השאלה של תו כניסה יציאה היא אפשר לחשוב עליה כי אינסטנט של מה שנקרא.
כן trade off בין תוחלת לשנות. כן שאתם בטח למדתם עליו והאמנו נכון?
ככה קראתם לא שם היה אז היה הטייה.
כן, הטייה בין מה בין כן הביא various trade בדיוק.
הרבה פעמים קוראים לזה באנגלית הבייס סיידוף. והרעיון הוא שבאחד נכון, בקצה אחד של הבייס וריד, אז trade off,
אתם בעצם לא מניחים יותר מדי לגבי הבעיה, כי אין אתם כמעט לא מניחים כלום, אבל אז גם יש לכם פחות.
בעצם יש לכם פחות מה שנקרא עמדה, כתב BIOS. כן, כלומר יש לכם פיגום יותר דלים שבאמצעותם אתם ממנפים את הלמידה.
אתם צריכים ללמוד יותר כי אתם מניחים פחות נכון, ובצד השני אתם מניחים הרבה ואז אתם צריכים ללמוד פחות.
אבל מצד שני אולי ההנחות האלה לא לגמרי נכונות ואתם מפסידים משהו.
אתם מקטינים את הבר כבר, אבל יוצרים איזשהו בייס.
אפשר לחשוב ככה במידה רבה גם על שאלת הסגמנט סיה בעצם האם לקחת את הטקסט ולחלק אותו לתווים או לא יודע משהו מאוד כללי, כזה שלא מניח כמעט כלום,
או לעשות משהו שמניח יותר כמו חלוקה מורפולוגית עשירה ומבוססת על המון כללים שאולי נותן לנו מידע חשוב לגבי המבנה של השפה ומקל את הלמידה,
אבל במקרים מסוימים עשוי כן לגרום נזקים.
אז אוקיי, אז באנגלית זה בדרך כלל המצב בעברית הרבה פעמים או בערבית לדוגמה.
כן, ברוב הדוגמאות גם בעברית ובאנגלית, אבל הוספתי גם קצת בגרמנית וערבי.
אז כן, אז בעברית הרבה פעמים יפרידו את הכלי טקסט סכם את המילים האלה.
אז נגיד לבית הספר יהפוך לבית הספר.
אוקיי, זה תהיה תו כניסה צידי מקובלת. בגרמנית.
יש שם דוברי גרמנית. לא. אוקיי, אז אולי הדוגמה הזאת לא זה, אבל זה גם מין כן Connection כזה.
כן, שתי מילים העובדה שלפעמים הוגים אותם בשפת הדיבור ואז גם יפרידו את זה.
אבל סך הכל משהו די מינימלי. כן, אבל בסדר, אבל צריך לקחת את המקורות למרות שיש רק את האחרים.
אז רק את אלה עם הפוסט רוף לאו דווקא ES.
נגיד נכון, כמו כמו שנתתי שם NT או עין שאמרתי כן, אבל משום מה זה מה שהיום אנחנו רואים היום גם כן.
כן, בדיוק. זה מאוד מאוד מינימלי, בדרך כלל באנגלית עוד סוג של ניתוח מורפולוגי מאוד נפוץ.
זה מה שנקרא לי מתיזה ציה. לא יודע אם נתקלתם בזה, כבר לא למדתי.
זה הציל בגדול. כשאומרים למה זה זה כן זה.
אני חושב מיוונית אומר זה אומר מילה פשוט, אבל מה שזה.
מה שאומר למוטיבציה זה מושג טכני שבגדול אומר להבהיר את המילה לצורת הבסיס שלה.
מה זה צורת בסיס? גם כאן יש קונבנציות שונות, אבל בגדול זה יהיה דברים כמו לוותר על ריבוי,
כמו לקחת פועל ולזרוק את הנטיות שלו ולהעביר אותו לאיזה שהיא צורה קנונית או משהו כזה.
כן, אז נגיד דג זה יהפוך לדוג וכלבים יהפוך לכלב ויש כאן דוברי ערבית בקהל.
כן כן נכון. אז כלב יהפוך לקל. כן שוב זה אתה דוגמה פשוט בכמה שפות שונות.
וכפי שאתם רואים זה לאו דווקא אומר להשמיט.
לפעמים זה אומר להשמיט חלק מוספיות נכון כמו בכלבים כלב Dogs דוג, אבל לפעמים זה אומר משהו קצת יותר מתוחכם.
כן, תלוי בכמה הנטייה באותה שפה היא מורכבת.
כן takes לתייק איתנו נתן וכן הלאה.
עכשיו. האם מה זה אומר לגבי?
לא יודע מה צריך לעשות אם יינתן, מה צריך לעשות שם?
צריך להפוך את זה למטען ולהשאיר את זה באותו בניין או להגיד לא.
כל המילים מאותו בניין כולם עוברות לנון טפלון כי זה השורש וזה הלמה.
שוב עניין של קונבנציות, תלוי באיזה סכמה אתם עוסקים, אבל זה בדרך כלל הכוונה.
כשמדברים על למתי זה כן על ההפיכה ללמוד.
בחלק מהשפות יש מבנה פנימי כאמור יותר מורכב ואז לפעמים מסטיק מנטה ציה.
שוב, זה תלוי בסכמה שאתם עובדים בה, אבל לעיתים אתם תראו, עוסק בנטייה יותר שאפתנית.
כן, שלא רק מפרידה.
כן קלי איקס כן, כמו לבית הספר מפרידה את הלבד וכן הלאה ובה אלא ממש נכנסת יותר להקיש כיס של המילה ומתחילה לחלק אותה לחתיכות גם בתוך הכלי.
מה שנקרא מי שכאן יש לו קצת רקע. בבלשנות זה נקרא מורפולוגיה, גזירת טית, כלומר לא רק הנטיות אלא ממש את הצורה שבה המילה הזאת נגזרה.
כן, זה דיון שלא ניכנס אליו, אבל נגיד מטבחון, כלים נכון, מטבחון, כלים.
אז פיגמנטציה יותר רדיקלית כזאת תגיד שזה בעצם מטבח און, ואם נגיד שזה כבר משהו יותר משמעותי מאשר להפריד כלי טקסט כן אורבניות כן.
אפשר להגיד והניו על זה פשוט מילה באנגלית כן ביחיד.
אז גם לא צריך להפריד את האס אפילו. כן אין אס.
אבל גם היא כן רואים לך. היא נגזרה.
זה בעצם רי. נכון שזה מין מרפא מה שאומרת מה?
שוב, נכון שוב לעשות משהו שוב ואז ניוז זה בעצם כן זה.
זה מה שנקרא לפעמים סתם כאילו המרכז של המילה הגזע.
ועל זה מה? מה ההבדל בין מיניו לבין על מה?
כן בדיוק. זה משהו שהופך פה פועל לשם עצם הרבה פעמים בשבוע.
בסדר ובגרמנית. אבל זה לפעמים מה שרק רציתי להראות בדוגמא הזאת, זה שלפעמים הופך אותם גם לא רציפות.
כן, ואז זה גם מסבך, כי זה כבר לא רק חלוקה לחתיכות.
זה גם צריכים, גם חתיכות לא רציפות. כן, ויש את זה בחלק מהשפות שבעצם יש מרפא.
מה שאומרת תוסיף גם בהתחלה וטיפ בסוף.
בסדר ואז גם את זה צריך לייצג את זה שוב. אז רק כדי להראות לכם את מין קמצוץ מהמורכבות של העניין.
אבל ברמה הטיפוסית מה שעושים זה פשוט סגמנט סי.
אז הנה דוגמה לקורפוס בעברית כן, אתם יכולים למצוא אותו כאן.
הוא הוא שהוא כאן מנותח לפי הסכמה של אוניברסיטת פנסילבניה.
עוד מעט נדבר עליה. אז הנה, אתם יכולים לקרוא את המשפט זה צורה טיפוסית שבה מציגים קורפוס.
יש לכם את האינדקס, אתם רואים פה המקף שם?
יש לכם את האינדקס של התוכן? אוקיי.
יש לכם לפעמים מילה מסוימת מקבלת שני אינדקסים, או אולי שלושה או ארבעה.
אתם רואים כמה היא מורכבת? אז דבר ראשון מחלקים את זה כאילו לפי הרווחים מין חלוקה גסה ואז אם יש חלוקה פנימית אז יש לכם מין תוכן שכתוב ארבע עד חמש.
כן המתנוססת ואז ארבע אומר מתנוססת ואז סליחה ארבע אומר אלף וחמש אומר מתנוססת כן ובראש זה בראש וכן הלאה וכן האומנותי וכדומה.
ובמקביל בערוץ סרטים פיננסי. זה גם מאוד טיפוסי לראות עוד אותו עם הלמה של המילה, אז אתם גם יכולים להתרשם כאן.
אז הרבה פעמים זה פשוט יהיה אותו דבר. אבל לפעמים, נגיד מתנוססת, יעביר אותו לצורת עבר.
גוף שלישי יחיד כן התנוסס או איזה עוד מקרים?
אז כן, אז סגנון כאילו שהוא חלק מסגנונו, נכון?
אז הוא בעצם נגמר בנון לא סופית כי זה פשוט חתכנו באמצע מילה.
אבל עלמא היא אין סופית ואומנים או אומן ארמני משום מה הם הפכו להרמן, אבל הוא לא יודע.
אולי זה טעות פשוט זה נראה לי קצת מוזר, אז אולי אני קצת מפספס משהו?
וכן הלאה. אוקיי, אז אתם מבינים את הרעיון? כן, אני מקווה.
שאלות כן. אז בעצם? התשובה שלי בעצם הראשון והשני.
כן כן כן, זה בדיוק כן.
כן, אבל זה נתן לי לחזור על המשפט הזה.
אוקיי, לא, לא התקבל אינדקס אחר. כן, אז נגיד למשל, בה הוא גם המילה 19 וגם המילה 26.
האינדקסים זה פשוט כדי לסמן את. הנה נגיד, הוא בפירוט כן, אז.
או משהו כזה? נכון, זה הכוונה. מה בדיוק?
הוא קיבל שלושה אינדקסים ואז שמנו אותם. בסדר.
עוד שאלות. בסדר, אז יש לו כניסה ציה וספציפית גם למוטיבציה במקרה הזה.
אבל כפי שאתם רואים, היו יכולים גם לעשות את זה, אחרת היו יכולים להחליט לפרק את ציפורים לציפור ואם.
וכל מיני דברים אחרים, אבל זה הסכמה שנבחרה כאן שאלות לגבי זה לפני שאנחנו עוברים את הפרק הבא.
פסוקיות אוקיי, המושג השני היסודי שנרצה לדבר עליו כשאנחנו מדברים על טוק, זה מה שנקרא פסוקית או קלוז.
אז מה זה בעצם פסוקית? גם כאן אני לא אתן בדיוק הגדרה מדויקת, כי גם זה נושא שנוי במחלוקת ותאוריות שונות יגדירו פסוקית בצורה קצת אחרת.
בקיצור, אם אתם אוהבים ויכוחים אז בלשנות זה כנראה התחום בשבילכם.
אבל מה ש אינטואיטיבית זה אומר זה שבעצם פסוקית זה איזשהו תיאור של מצב או פעולה או תכונה כן ובהרבה שפות בעצם.
וזה איזושהי יחידה בסיסית.
כן, איזושהי יחידה בסיסית יש שיטענו בכל השפות או הדעה המקובלת ובכל השפות שבעצם מבצעת מה שנקרא פרי דיקציה,
כלומר טוענת איזה שהיא טענה מבטאת איזשהו יחס וכן הלאה.
עכשיו באנגלית יחסית קל לזהות פסוקיות, כי בגדול פסוקיות מתאימות באנגלית לפעלים עד כדי כמה יוצאי דופן קטנים.
אבל בגדול פסוקית יש פועל. כן.
אז אם אתם רואים פועל אתם יודעים שהוא מרכז, כן או הוא חלק מן פסוקית.
האם פסוקיות יכולות להיות כן, לפעמים פסוקיות פשוטות כמו נגיד רק נושא ומושא.
אוקיי, כן, בסאבטקסט בפרויקט באנגלית כמו אופרנד או הדלת נפתחה בעברית.
לפעמים יכולות להכיל עוד ארגון סמנטיים נכון, כמו מושא מושא ישיר.
במקרה הזה לא יודע אם אתם זוכרים. אם לא, אני קצת תנסה להשתמש במושגים זה.
לא אני עכשיו הולך לזרוק עליכם קצת הרבה מושגים. אוקיי, אבל אני בכוונה מפריד בין המושגים הכי יסודיים שאותם צריך לדעת ולהכיר, כי נשתמש בהם כל הזמן,
כמו מה זה פסוקית ומה זה מילה, ועוד מעט גם מה זה נאו פרייז, ביטוי שמני ועוד הרבה מושגים אחרים שאני אזרוק שטוב שתתרגלו אליהם.
כן, אבל ברור שזה לא קורס בבלשנות, אבל זה טוב שתתרגלו כי הם מופיעים לפעמים.
אז גם ככה זה פועל. אז כאן אתם רואים ששני הארגומנט הם גם מושא וגם מושא, ולפעמים גם יש כל מיני תיאורים.
כן, כמו במקרה כאן תיאור אופן בתור כלי Open וג'ון open גדול וזה הם כן,
אז הם עם תיאור של אינסטרומנטס של מכשיר כן, ולפעמים יש לנו בעצם באנגלית מקרים שבהם הפ רדיקל ציה כן,
הנשוא הוא בעצם מבוטא על ידי תואר,
ובמקרה הזה באנגלית מחייבת אותנו בכל זאת להוסיף פועל כן או סוג של פועל נקרא אוגד גם בעברית או באנגלית זה נקרא קופי עולה,
שכן שחייבים גם להכניס אותו כמו ג'ון Install.
אבל בשפות אחרות חביבות עליכם כמו נגיד איזה שפה לא מחייבת אתכם להכניס מין פועל עזר כזה עברית למשל, נכון?
או ערבית או היה או הרוסי נכון?
בדיוק אז הקופי עולה זה תחום מאוד מעניין קופי.
אז אגב, אם ככה מעניין אתכם הבדלים בין שפות, יש הבדלים מאוד משמעותיים בין שפות בשימוש בקופי, אם בכלל.
כן, בדרך כלל יש איזה שהוא קופי אולה, אבל, אבל יכולים להיות לו מגוון שימושים וזה מעשה מילה מאוד מאוד מאוד רב משמעית.
כן. ה is r זה דבר מאוד מעניין, אבל באמת נושא לקורס אחר.
אז יפה אז אלה פסוקיות הפשוטות, כן או אלה בעצם פסוקיות במופע הכי פשוט שלהם, שבהם הן פשוט מהוות משפט.
כן, יש לי משפט. זה משפט שהוא סך הכל די פשוט.
יש בו טרי, דיקציה אחת כן, יש פה בסופן. אולי.
נושא אולי מושא, אולי תיאורים, אולי מושא עקיף, מושא ישיר.
לא יודע מה כל מיני דברים כאלה, אבל סך הכל יש התאמה אחד לאחד בין משפט לבין פסוקית.
אוקיי, זה המקרה הפשוט, אבל לפעמים יש לנו משפטים.
כמובן שבהם יש כמה פסוקיות ואז הם מחוברים באחת מ.
בגדול אפשר לומר ארבע דרכים שונות.
כן, שוב. קצת משתנים, אבל אני מפשט מפשט את הנושא.
בגדול, משפטים מורכבים הם מורכבים מכמה פסוקיות שביניהם מחוברות ואחת מארבעה דגמים עיקריים.
הראשונה זה מה שנקרא פסוקיות מושא. או באנגלית component class.
כן. במקרה הזה זה בעצם מקרה שבה פסוקית ממש משמשת כאחד הארגומנט טים בין פסוקית אחרת.
אוקיי, אז יש לי איזשהו פרדיקס ואחד הרומנטיים שלו הרבה פעמים מוסר, אבל לאו דווקא זה.
גם במקרים מסוימים יכול להיות נושא הוא עצמו מהווה פסוקית.
כן. אז במקרה הכי פשוט זה פשוט מושא.
ואז זה יהיה דברים כמו הרבה פעמים זה יהיה עם מילים של מה שקרה.
Reported speech. כן. לאו דווקא, אבל הרבה פעמים כן כמו Send כן reported או דברים משהו שאני ראיתי, כן קישור ואז יש מישהו בעט בכדור נכון?
או בעט בכדור או הוא יבעט בכדור.
זה פעולה אחת. נכון? זה מה שקראנו. זה המופע הפשוט ביותר.
פסוקית שהיא גם משפט, אבל לפעמים אי אפשר להגיד שמישהו יבעט בכדור.
אלא שמישהו חושב שמישהו יבעט בכדור או שמישהו אמר שמישהו איבד בכדור,
או שמישהו ראה שמישהו עומד לבעוט בכדור וכן הלאה וכן הלאה, ואז זה יהווה בעצם פסוקית מושא.
אוקיי, זה קונפליקט כוח. כן, לפעמים הוא גם מופיע בצורה כזאת באנגלית Mary, קווינס Fall Two.
ג'וינטים? כן, אז זה בעצם פסוקית שהיא לא בצורה הרגילה שלה.
כן, היא לא כמו פול well, ג'ון להם או כן או פול, אלא זה עובר לטור.
אבל אוקיי, לא משנה, זה גם איזשהו סוג של complex close, אז זה צורה אחת.
פסוקית משמשת כארגון מנטלי פסוקית אחרת.
השני זה מה שנקרא cold nation. כן, קודם nation זה אני חושב בעברית נקרא כן משפט מאוחה כאילו שאיחרו אותו.
אבל לא משנה המושג שאנחנו נשתמש בזה קודם איישם.
במקרה כאן יש לנו בעצם בדרך כלל שימוש במילה וכן או אין דומה.
לפעמים זה גם דברים אחרים כמו בת ולא דר או דברים כאלה.
אבל הרעיון פה זה לקחת שני משפטים כן או שתי פסוקיות ולשים אותם באיזשהו מובן אחד לצד השני.
כן, ממש מעמד כמעט סימטרי. כן, הוא לא בדיוק סימטרי, כי יש הבדל בין להגיד נכון להגיד טוק אשר אין טעם לבין להגיד את הקשה השוואה.
נכון שזה מה ההבדל? סתם כשאתם שומעים זה כן אולי סדר הזמן או משהו כזה.
אז זה לא שאני טוענת שזה סימטרי במובן שזה לחלוטין פרפראזה, אבל סך הכל מבחינה תחבירית הם נמצאים במעמד מקביל.
זה נקרא code nation. כן. סוג נוסף זה מה שנקרא ולעתים close כן פסוקיות זיקה ששם זה בעצם אפשר לומר שזה פסוקית שמשמשת כסוג של תיאור כן כסוג של מודי פאר.
אז במקום תואר אני יכול להשתמש בפסוקים במקום במקום להגיד לא יודע מה.
ג'ון החכם גם כן מדבר גרמנית היטב.
אז אני יכול להגיד ג'ון, שלמד את השפה במשך שנים, מדבר גרמנית היטב.
כן, אז זה בעצם מהווה איזשהו סוג של תיאור או דוגמה אחרת.
כלבים שלא נובחים לא נושכים אף פעם.
כן? אז שוב אותו רעיון. יש לי פה איזושהי פסוקית שבה כלבים נובחים, נכון, אבל הדבר הזה משמש כדי לתאר כן כדי להוסיף איזשהו תיאור.
למה במקרה כאן לאיזה מילה הדוגמה הזאת לדוקטורט, נכון?
אז בעצם יש לי כאן מין. אתם יכולים לחשוב על זה כדוגמא spark ודב never byte ועכשיו איכשהו אחדות אתם ביחד, לא?
כן, זה לא בדיוק שייחדו אותם ביחד מבחינה סמנטית, אבל מבחינה תחבירית איחדו את שני המשפטים האלה יחד והמקרה האחרון זה מין קצת כלבו ענק.
כן, קצת מין אוסף כזה, אבל בגדול זה קולע. קוראים לזה לפעמים לינק Close.
אז כן, זה מחוברים בדרכים שונות ומשונות, לפעמים באמצעות מילות קישור.
כן disco אז קולקטיב כמו After Studies פה Use, ג'ון תצפית צ'פמן Where,
או במקרה זה יצא צדדית פויירשטיין חוץ Picture where או despite שדפקתי את סטטיסטית For years,
ג'ון כותנת picture, מניטו או כל מיני דברים כאלה ולפעמים לא.
לפעמים זה פשוט פסיק שאין איזושהי מילה וזה איכשהו מההקשר מבינים אם זה קשר של קונטרס או קשר של סדר זמני ביניהם או או או או או כל סוג קשר אחר.
אוקיי, אז כן, אז רק משפט אחרון.
אז בגדול כן ברמה כן, ברמה הגלובלית אנחנו נדבר על פסוקיות שהן יכולות או להופיע כמו משפטים בפני עצמם,
או שאנחנו נוכל לדבר על משפטים מורכבים שמורכבים מתתי פסוקיות, לפעמים גם יותר משתיים שמורכבות אחת עם השנייה באחד מהדגמים שאנחנו רואים כאן.
כן, בדיוק כמו כדי.
כן, אז זה גם כאן. כל זה, כאמור, כל הדפים, כל קטגוריה ציורית של כל משפט, אז אני מניח, אני אלך הביתה כדי לעשות כן.
כן, עוד שאלה. כן, למה משהו?
כן. אז מה השאלה?
כל זה לא טוב. אה?
מה לא בעצם? יש כאן שתי פסוקיות. כן.
בעצם הצורה שאנחנו עוד לא דיברנו על הדרך שבה אנחנו ממש מייצגים את זה.
פורמלית זה השקף הבא. אבל מה שרק רציתי לומר כאן זה שאפשר לחשוב על זה בעצם כמין פסוקית,
שזה גם הדרך שבה בדרך כלל מקודדים את זה, כי פסוקית שהיא מקוננת בתוך פסוקית אחרת שבעצם יש לך משהו.
כמו כן, במה מרי שכנעה את פול?
אה, אוקיי, זה הדבר הזה שהוא בעצמו פסוקית.
כן, אבל באותה.
הרעיון של לקרוא לזה קופלמן קלוז זה כי לפעמים אפשר גם להחליף את זה בשם עצם.
כמו מרי שכנע את פול בנכונות טענותיה.
נגיד או משהו כזה? כן כן.
או לא? לבין אתם קלוז מנהלים.
אה כן. אז שאלה טובה.
הסיבה שרציתי לתת לזה כאן מעמד ייחודי וכמובן זה זה הכל.
הכל פה הוא דיבייט. כן, אבל סך הכל הסיבה שפרטתי קודם היא של קליקות.
למשל, יש מאפיינים די ייחודיים הרבה פעמים שגורם להרבה סכמות לייחד לו קטגוריה נפרדת.
נגיד, לדוגמה, אפשר לראות כאן כן, ההשמטה של הפועל החוזר כן.
ההשמטה של הפועל החוזר. אז תשים לב שאי שהוא הפועל, גם של קרטון וגם של תו בשאר רואה כן, הוא מופיע רק פעם אחת.
אבל אה כן, בדיוק הנושא של המשפט. אבל נגיד כאן, למרות שיש את אותה נושא לשניהם, לא כל כך הייתי יכול להגיד After studies אולי בשפות מסוימות.
כן, באנגלית זה לא היה עובד, כן? After student פוירשטיין כן where.
יותר סתמי מדברייך. After סטנדינג את פריז.
נכון לא? אתה צודק. אז אני רק אומר שאתה צודק.
זה כבר צורה תחבירית אחרת אני לא טוען שאני טועה.
הדבר היחידי שאני טוען זה שיש הרבה פעמים לקוד DNA של מאפיינים תחביריים ייחודיים, שהוא לא חולק עם משפטים שבנויים בצורה הזאת.
כן, מה שלפעמים נקרא סבואה Addition גם וכן זה בקורסים בבלשנות.
אז נכון, לומדים הרבה על ההבדל בין ספרדי מישל כורדי מיישם, אני מניח, עדיין נכון, ולמעשה יש כאלה.
יש. יש גם כאלה שיטענו שבשפת מסוימות יש קוסה.
בויד מיישם כן, כלומר, יש מין דרגת ביניים בין שני הדברים האלה והכל פה.
כאמור, אני מציג לכם איזושהי תמונה פלקטית של תחום מאוד מורכב, אבל פשוט כדי שיהיה לנו איזשהי שפה משותפת לדבר טוב.
אז ביטויים שמני גם מפייס?
אז כן, אז זה. אז כאמור, אם דיברנו על שני המושגים הבסיסיים עד כה בדקדוק שאמרתי שמשתמש בהם כל הזמן שהם.
מילה ולא פסוקית, כן, אז זה היה השלישי.
כאילו שאנחנו שוב שלושת אלה שאם אם יצאתם מהשיעור הזה כשאתם מבינים מה זה אומר נאו פרייז אז class ו world,
אז סך הכל או אני חושב למרות שאני מקווה שתפיק שתספיקו יותר מזה.
אבל זה באמת אחד משלושת הביטויים המרכזיים. אז דן פרייז זה ביטוי שמני.
בגדול, אפשר לומר או דרך אחת לחשוב עליו זה כאיזשהו ביטוי איזשהו צירוף שהוא יכול להוות הארגומנט כן, כמו נושא או נושא של פסוקית.
ויש לנו כי אני לא יודע למה כתבתי פה טום מייג'ור קלאס, אז יש לנו free מייג'ור קלאס.
אז כן, זה סתם type או שהם מנויים לכם כאן שאנחנו נדבר עליהם האחד מהם זה מה שנקרא רפרנס.
נכון שנתקלנו בהם כשדיברנו על Party speech או שמות לסוגיהם שהם בפני עצמם Non friends.
כן, כמו שמות של מקומות לונדון או שמות של אנשים.
כן אומרי או שמות של ארגונים.
האוניברסיטה העברית. אז זה סוג אחד שהם בפני עצמם מהווים נאום Face או יכולים להוות נאום Faces לכשעצמם.
חוץ מזה, יש לנו מה שנקרא את הקוד מנאוס.
כן Commons שהם שוב תלוי בשפה, אבל הם הרבה פעמים לא.
או שלא יכולים להופיע בעצמם, או שגם הם יכולים להופיע בעצמם.
הרבה פעמים יופיעו אם בהרבה קשרים יופיעו עם עוד כל מיני חתיכות שמתלוות אליהם וחתיכות שמתלוות אליהם.
יחד עם השם ביחד נקרא להם צירוף שמני כביסה מתחרה.
האמנם זה? מה אני מתכוון? אז למשל, אם יש לכם קומבינה, תנו לי דוגמה.
כלב נגיד סתם מי נותן?
אז אפשר לדבר על נכון על כלב.
אפשר לדבר גם על כלב מהיר או כלב איטי נכון?
או כלבים מהירים ואיטיים? אפשר להוסיף להם relative clothes.
כן כן, כמו למשל כלבים נובחים בקול רם.
כן פסוקיות זיקה אלה אפשר להוסיף להם עוד זוכה.
ידין אז כמו שמונה הכלבים נובחים בקול רם או.
הכלב הראשון אי פעם שדווח בקול רם או כל מיני דברים כאלה.
לפעמים יש מופיעים בתוך קונפרנס. כן, כמו shipping Company.
נכון, חברת ספנות אז חברת ספנות היא סוג של ספנות או סוג של חברה.
זה סוג של חברה. נכון? אז בעצם גם כאן יש לי אחד שהוא.
למרות שיש לי כמה notes, אחד מהם הוא הראשי, הוא קובע.
אנחנו תכף נדבר על זה, הוא קובע את הטיפוס של הנאם פייס והאחרים מתלווים אליו, מוסיפים עליו.
כן, אלברט ערבית. בסדר.
ואז השלישי אה, אני רואה שהייתי קונסיסטנטי בזה ששמתי את השלישי גם שם וגם שם.
אוקיי, אז סליחה, זה שלישי שהתכוונתי לכתוב כאן ולא זוכר למה מחקתי.
זה מה שנקרא problems. כן שזה כינויי גוף.
כן הוא אני אתם האלו וכן הלאה.
אוקיי, אז זה כינוי בדרך כלל לנעם פרייז מהסוג השני לפחות כן, אני לא מדבר על כינויי גוף, על פופר ליונס.
יש להם גרעין כן או מה שנקרא הד. כן, יש להם גרעין הד, שזה שהיא מילה שבעצם קובעת את הטיפוס הסמנטי של הטיפוס הסמנטי של הצירוף השמה.
כן, כלומר, אפשר לומר שכל הצירוף ה ימני כולו הוא סוג של משהו מהקטגוריה של הגרעין.
אז למשל, אם יש לי company כאמור יצרתי פה company וגם אם יהיה לי one of the free לידי world y leading shipping companies.
ההזהרות כל המילים האלה זה עדיין סוג של company נכון?
ואם זה יש company company זה הקרוז שלי reported to be on the Verge או בין פפסי אז עדיין יש סוג של קורטני, נכון?
למרות שיש לי שם עוד הרבה מילים אחרים, אחרות פסוקיות וכל מיני דברים אחרים.
אוקיי, אז זה בעצם הרעיון וזה קובע את הריבוי נכון, אם זה יחיד או רבים זה קובע את הסוג הסמנטי וכן הלאה.
אז יש כל מיני מולטי Files, אבל אפשר לדבר בהרבה מקרים שוב לכל דבר יש יוצאי דופן, אבל בגדול בהרבה מקרים בטח שניתקל בהם יהיה גרעין לביטוי יש שם.
כן, אפשר לחזור בקצרה להבין שלושה סוגים.
אה כן, בטח. שלישי, אני משום מה מחקתי אותו, אבל בטעות.
אז שלושת הסוגים הם כאלה. אחד מהם זה proper names.
שזה מה. שמעת?
כן. אוקיי. שהם ביטויים שמנים בפני עצמם. הם לא חייבים להיות נכון.
אפשר להגיד משהו כמו האוניברסיטה העברית, האוניברסיטה הטובה ביותר בישראל וביקום.
נגיד משהו כזה, נכון? אבל אפשר גם פשוט להגיד את זה בתור הנושא או המושא של המשפט.
נכון, את השם אז פרופ ברנר יש come nurse.
זה שמות כמו מיינארד או נאו פרייז קומן.
בעצם אז head words. כן כן, מילות גרעין.
אז זה הכוונה. מילים שהם שמות של קטגוריה כמו כלבים או חברות או כיתות או.
כן, כולל כולם מושגים אבסטרקטי רפובליקות.
אמרתי בסדר, שהם הרבה פעמים יופיעו עם מודי First Scan.
הם יופיעו עם כל מיני דברים שמוסיפים עוד מידע על בסיס השם של הקטגוריה, שהוא כמו תארים, פסוקיות, זיקה.
הנה כתבתי כאן, כן, כל מיני דברים שונים.
כן, כמו כמויות, כן כמתים. כן, מילים שבעצם הם חלק מצירוף יחד איתם.
כן, נגיד ביטוי סמיכות. בסדר. אז חברת ספנות נכון, אמרנו זה סוג של חברה, אז זה בעצם השני והשלישי.
מה הוא? כינוי?
בסדר, זה הנוער שלה. כן כן כן טוב.
בסדר. ומסתבר שהמושג הזה של Headstart הוא מושג מאוד שימושי בעיבוד שפה טבעית.
כל כך שימושי שבעצם רוב הניתוחים תחביריים בעיבוד שפה טבעית משתמשים כיום בסכמה שנקראת או בצורת ייצוג תחבירי.
שנקראת דיפנס Structure. אוקיי, או מבני תלויות שבהם אלה גם היום מבנים תחביריים שאנחנו נעסוק מהם בקורס הזה,
שבעצם מנסות להעמיד את כל המבנה התחבירי על יסוד המושג הזה שנקרא גרעין אוקיי,
מנסים למצוא גרעינים Heads AdWords בכל מקום, וכדי לתאר את הכל הקשרים בין AdWords לבין דיפנדר.
כלומר מילים שתלויות בהם. כן, אז נגיד למשל, אם יש לי לא יודע חברת ספנות בינלאומית, אז אני חושב על ספנות ובינלאומית בתור.
אם הם לא אוגרים אז הם תלויים. כן, הם דיפנדר, ועכשיו הרעיון הוא לנסות להפוך כל דבר למבנים של Heads וה דיפנדר.
אז אוקיי, אז בינהם faces לפחות מהסוג של coming out.
סך הכל מצבנו פשוט נכון. אם יש shipping company אז company.
יואב פשוט נגיד שפעם עוד דיפנדר and פסטו.
אני קניתי runner וואי גרעין fast true דיפנדר.
אתה תלוי בו. דמיאן רוזנברג אז כאן כבר יש שתי.
אפשר לחשוב על זה כשני דיפנדר. נכון, אחד זה תלוי גם והשני זה הוא הסטנדרט.
כן, שהוא איזשהו פסוקית זיקה.
אז שם המקרה יחסית פשוט, אבל ביטויים שמנים ובטח ביטויים שמנים מהסוג של קומבינה זה רק חלק מהסיפור.
מה לגבי פסוקיות? אז לגבי פסוקיות צריך להחליט מהו הגרעין.
אין לזה תשובה כל כך. סטרייק Forward, כמו במקרים של כן של עקום מנומס כן או comment או מקרים של נאם פרייז שהאחד שלהם הוא כל מנה.
אז מה שבדרך כלל סכמות למבנה תלויות עושות זה בעצם מוצאות את הפרויקט.
כן, נגיד למשל באנגלית זה יהיה לרוב הפועל עם מאיזשהו יוצא דופן מרכזי שנדבר עליו תכף, אבל זה יהיה בגדול.
הפועל הראשי של הפסוקית ושאר הדברים ייחשבו כדי Pants שלו.
אז למשל ג'ון ורנון רן. פה הוא הפועל הראשי, אז הוא יחשב כגרעין של ג'ון האם, של הפסוקית וג'ון וג'ון והם יהיו דיפנדר, Build Stupid, ליאן said.
אופס, US coaching. אז כאן מה יהיה הגרעין?
אין סרט כי זה הפועל הראשי. ומה יהיו את הדיפנדר זקן התלויים בו?
כמה יש. 3.
אוקיי, מי הם? Stupid לי.
הסרט יופי של כושר ובים.
אוקיי, אז כאילו אומרים יש פה שלושה דברים שאחד מהם הוא בעצמו גם יש לו מבנה פנימי נכון של אחד מהם גם מורכב בעצם מכמה מילים שהוא טיפוס על סוויץ.
אוקיי, ואז אוקיי, אז זה הרעיון הבסיסי.
אנחנו אומרים אוקיי, אנחנו אוהבים את הרעיון הזה של לתאר תחביר ככה קשרי תלות בין גרעין לבין טיפוס, בין דברים שתלויים בו.
אז אנחנו ננתח פסוקיות, כך שהרבה מתאים.
כן, הנושא המושא. תיאורים. כן, כל מיני אלמנטים של הפסוקית יהיו Department של הפועל הראשי,
שיחשב כגרעין וננתח מהו פרייז ככאלה שבהם כל כן מודי first האלה למיניהם, He is relative close קרדינלס או הדינר?
אז מה? הדיפאיינט זה terminal? אז כל הדברים האלה ישמשו כדי פנס של הגרעין.
אז זאת האינטואיציה או זה לפחות ההחלטה המרכזית.
אבל עכשיו מה זה אומר בפועל? איך אנחנו לוקחים משפט שלם ומנתחים אותו על בסיס הרעיון הזה, כך שבסוף נקבל איזשהו מבנה שנוכל לקרוא לו מבנה תחבירי.
אז נצא לרבע שעה הפסקה ואחרי זה נדון באיך עושים את זה.
לפחות. מלשכת שר.
פשוט. מה לעשות?
זה לא סתם, וזה נראה לכם אפשרי לדפוק את השני של חיית המחמד שלכם?
אה? טוב. יש משהו חשוב שלא משנה כמה שמעת על זה, לא משנה.
משהו קטן שאולי.
אנחנו עושים נכון, ולעיתים יש לנו לחכות ולראות מה הסדרה של הניסוי הזה.
זו ההסתברות הכי גבוהה של. אנחנו רוצים עכשיו לשבת על הכיסא הזה מאחורה.
זה שיושב עכשיו. הייתי במקום אחר.
כן. 13.
יהיה אפשר להאיץ. ככה זה עכשיו.
אתה יכול. זה לא שאתה מתחיל מאפס או מגלגל את זה.
החוק החדש יכול לתת את המקסימום ביחס למה אתה כאילו עוקב אחרי הפרסומות שבהם בחר מראש הדרך עד שהגעת למקום.
מקסימות בכישרון. כאילו בקצה של המפה, נכון?
כן, אני רואה שזה פשוט איפשהו שכולם צריכים כאילו מגיע לשכבה האחרונה ואז יש לך את המרקסיזם הגלובלי ואז כן.
ואם יש לך כמה שניות זה חוזר על עצמו. בחרתי לעשות את הסרט הזה.
אוקיי, אז זה אומר שיש כמה פצצות? הייתי.
ובין היתר מדם. כן.
כן. אוקיי, אז נמשיך.
אז סיימנו את השיעור הקודם בכך שדיברנו על.
דיברנו על המרכזיות של ניתוח כהן בין אגפי.
ובעצם עמדנו בדיוק לפני הצגה של מה זה אומר מבנה תלויות?
מה זה אומר לנתח משפט ניתוח תחבירי באמצעות מיפוי של.
תיאור הקשרים בין עץ? אז אוקיי, אז הנה הרעיון.
הרעיון בעצם אומר כך. הצורה שאנחנו נעשה את זה זה בעצם בצורה רקורסיבית.
אנחנו ניקח משפט. המשפט או כן ניקח משפט, נזהה במשפט הזה מה יהיה התפקיד העיקרי ולה יש פועל עיקרי כן או בדיקת רוב פעמים זה יהיה פועל.
ואותה נסמן בתור שורש של העץ שלו.
בסדר? עכשיו לשורש הזה יש כמה דברים שתלויים בו, דברים שתלויים בו מיידית.
יהיו בעצם הרכיבים בתוך הפסוקית העיקרית.
כן, אז נגיד נושא עמוסה תיאורים לסוגיהם, מילות שלילה וכל מיני דברים בסגנון הזה.
כל אחד מחתיכות האלה, כל אחד מהרכיבים האלה יהיה תת עץ.
אוקיי. יהיה תת עץ שנמצא מתחת לשורש.
אז נגיד אם יש לי את המשפט Fancy apartment ואנחנו נגיד אוקיי, הפסוקית המשפט הזה הוא ספציפית.
יש בה רק פסוקית אחת. ומטבע הדברים פסוקית הראשית יש פועל רק שהוא הפועל המרכזי במשפט, אז הוא יהיה השורש של העץ שלנו.
עכשיו לבובת יש הפסוקית הזאת יש בעצם שני רכיבים נוספים.
אחד זה דבר שהוא משרת את הנושא של המשפט והשני זה Defence, פרקליט שמשמש כמושא של המשפט.
אוקיי, כל אחד מהם מורכב מכמה מילים ולכן הוא בעצם מהווה תת עץ.
איך נראה המבנה הפנימי של אותו תת העץ? שוב, בגלל זה אני אומר אמרתי זה באופן רקורסיבי.
כן, נלך לתת העץ הזה ונשאל אוקיי, מה הוא במקרה בא מכן כאן שניהם כן, שני תתי העצים האלה.
גם דבר זה וגם Defence Apartment הם מה קראנו לזה קודם?
איזה יצור תחבירי הם? הם אמנם prices יד, אבל דבר ראשון הם אינם Faces.
ואילו כן בדיוק הם כאלה שאינם Faces שיש בהם בתור הדרואיד קומננוס.
כלומר יש להם בעצמם גרעין נכון בדפלציה פיגמנט מה הגרעין?
אחד מהם נכון, זה סוג של טירה ודבר כזה בעבר כן.
ויש עוד מילים נוספות. אז אוקיי, אז דבר ראשון אחרי שזיהינו את הגרעין מחבר, בעצם לא נצייר את תת העץ,
כי ברובד שמתחתיו יש תת עץ Defence Apartment באופן ישיר, אלא מסמן את צלע בן הדוד של הרמה העליונה לבין אחד של רמה אחת מתחת לפטמות.
אוקיי, וכנל בין רובד לבין PEG.
בסדר. ועכשיו שוב נפעיל ברקורסיה?
נשאל טוב Defence Apartment מה יש בו?
אז יש בו את הגרעין Apartment ויש לו שני מוטי First Fancy בזה.
אז אוקיי, אז אני מסמן עוד שני חצים שיוצאים פרגמנט והולכים לכל אחד מהם.
אלה כל אחד מהם כבר טוב בפני עצמו.
אז סיימנו את הצד הזה. כנל עם ברסלאו, מה שאתה לא זוכר.
וככה קיבלנו עץ.
אוקיי, כך קיבלנו עץ שבו לכל שבו בעצם יש לנו כן עץ עם שורש השורש זה הP, רדיקל העיקרי של המשפט הראשי, שהמשפט והסליחה הקודקודים של העץ הזה הם הטופ.
כן, זה שונים. כן, הם המילים השונות שנמצאות במשפט והם מחוברים אחד לשני בקשתות שמשקפים את היחסים ההיררכי ביניהם.
דבר אחד עוד לא אמרתי שמופיע כאן מולכם שזה העץ הזה, הוא לא סתם העץ בין הקודקודים שהם מילות המשפט, אלא יש לו עוד משהו.
מה אתם רואים מולכם חוץ מעץ הקודקודים של המילים של המשפט?
בכל מקרה המשמעות של מילה. כן בדיוק.
יש לי הקשתות האלה בלייבל. כן, יש להם לייבלים.
אז בעצם זה משהו שדי דומה קונספטואלית לפארק ספיץ?
כן, במובן הזה שיש לי סכמה, שהסכמה הזאת מגדירה מה הם הטיפוסים האפשריים של או מה הקטגוריות האפשריות של קשרים תחביריים,
וכל צלע מקבלת את אחת מהקטגוריות האלה. ככה זה לפחות מסכם אותה מקובלות.
אז טוב, אז יש לי. אז לגבי ואבדו פשוט השורש.
אז אין לו צלע נכנסת או לפעמים כדי לסמן אותו אז מוסיפים עוד דמי Not שנקרא root.
אוקיי, ואז שמים צלע נכנסת מוות אליו שנקראת זה רק עניין של קונבנציה שנקראת root ודבק הוא שם ג'קט ולכן הקשת שמחברת בין רוב לבין דג מסוג sub,
ג'קט ובפנסיה paint או ג'קט רושה.
אז כנל צלע הזאת תסומן כמו בצ'ק ויש לי צרות אחרות כמו בטעם בננה.
אז כן יתאים או High טיפול מועדף First כלומר תארים שמתארים איזשהו כן מתארים את מילת הגרעין וכן הלאה.
אז ככה אני מקבל איזשהו מבנה שהוא בעצם נקרא מבנה תלויות.
כן, עוד Pencil structure וניתוח של משפט נקרא Department פרשינג, ואנחנו נדבר כנראה בשבוע הבא כבר בעצם על איך עושים אותו גם באופן אוטומטי,
אבל כרגע אנחנו רק מתארים את הסכם עצמה עץ שבנוי על קודקודים שהם המילים או התוכן השונים במשפט והצלעות הם מחולקות לקטגוריות,
יש להם אלינו הסכמה שאנחנו נשתמש בה בקורס הזה.
אז חברה שנקראת University פיננסים ומתעניינים מוזמנים גם לבקר באתר באתר שלהם.
יש להם אתר מאוד מפורט עם המון המון דאטא שהם.
מלקקים אליו. זה בעצם סכמה שהפעילו אותה על יותר מ 100 שפות, והיא בעצם, אפשר לומר, היא לא בדיוק תיאוריה איזה, אלא מין.
בעצם אני אספר לכם איך לספר על היסטורית. אוקיי, אז אולי קצת תבינו מה טיב הסיפור.
מה שקרה זה שבעצם סכמות של מבנה תלויות התפתחו באיזשהו שלב נהיו מאוד פופולריות וכל שפה ולפעמים אפילו בשפה נתונה.
כמה סכמות שונות התפתחו כדי לתאר תופעות בשפה הזאת?
אוקיי, ומטבע הדברים לכל שפה יש מאפיינים קצת אחרים.
נכון, יש מאפיינים קצת אחרים באיך התחביר עובד.
יש שפות שיש להם נגיד למשל סימוני יחסה.
מה שנקרא נכון. יש כאן דוברי רוסית בקהל שהבנתי קודם, נכון, אז יש הטיות לפי יחסה נכון?
אם אני פונה אם אני מתאר אומר לא יודע הכלב כנושא או הכלב כמוסר או הכלב כמישהו שפונים אליו או הכלב כמשהו שמישהו שמקבל משהו.
כל הדברים האלה הם נשמעים קצת אחרת.
נכון, יש להם סיומת אחרת בעצם, אז זה נגיד צורה מסוימת של תחביר.
באנגלית זה לא קיים בעברית יש קצת שאריות היסטוריות של זה כמו ירושלימה או משהו כזה.
נכון אני או הביתה, אבל סך הכל אין כל כך אז וזו דוגמה אחת.
יש המון תופעות שהן ספציפיות לשפות ספציפיות, וזה בעצם מנע הרבה פעמים שיתוף ידע בין שפות ובין קורפוסים,
ואז בעצם היה מהלך מאוד כזה של כן, שהכניסו כמה שיותר אנשים תחת תחת אותה מטרייה.
כן, ואמרו אוקיי, עכשיו אנחנו נגיע שהיא פשרה היסטורית.
איזשהו אוסף גס יחסית. כן, קורס של קטגוריות שאפשר באמצעותם לתאר סט גדול מאוד של שפות.
כאמור, מעל ל 100 טוהרו בדרך הזאת, וכל סכמה תעבד קצת אולי מהמידע שהיא מקודדת,
אבל לפחות תהיה לנו איזשהי סטנדרטיזציה ויש לזה כל מיני יתרונות גם מבחינת ניתוח,
אבל גם ממש מבחינת Learning והיכולת שלנו להשתמש בדאטה בשפה אחת כדי לעזור בזה.
Data כדי לעזור לשפה אחרת, וגם על זה נדבר בהמשך הקורס.
כן, איך אנחנו יכולים בעצם ללמוד דאטה שעוסק באותה משימה כמו זאת שאנחנו רוצים לפתור, אבל הוא בכלל כתוב בשפה אחרת?
כן, ויש לזה לא מעט עבודה בנושא הזה.
אז בקיצור, יש הרבה יתרונות בלעשות סטנדרטיזציה וזה הרעיון של Universal.
אחרי ההקדמה הזאת, בוא נלמד קצת על איך היא עובדת. אוקיי, אז במקרה.
הם פשוטים. כן, היא עובדת בערך כמו הדוגמה הקודמת שראיתם.
אין כאן יותר מדי בעיות. ג'ון קיק דה פול דה דור, אורפנד כל הדברים האלה.
אין בעיה. יש לי לייבל שמתאר נושא או ספציפית נומינלי.
נושא שהוא צירוף שמני או ג'קט.
יש לי. יש לי גם עבור תיאורים כן, כמו תיאור זמן יסודי.
אז יש לי קטגוריה שמתאימה לתיאורים ובעצם הכל מתנהג בצורה מאוד סטנדרטית לגבי קופי דולז, או לפחות לגבי קופרס.
אז כאמור, בחלק מהשפות יש עוגנים שחייבים לשים אותם נכון כמו באנגלית ג'ון Install.
יש שפות שבהם במקרים מסוימים שמים אותם, אבל לא חייבים כמו.
עברי. נכון מאוד. נכון? ג'ון הוא גבוה או ג'ון גבוה?
שפות שבכלל אין את זה אלא רק את.
בכלל לא צריך קוקי אלא במקרים האלה. בקיצור, כדי לעשות איזושהי סטנדרטיזציה החליטו שהפרוייקט הסמנטי הוא מה שנקרא.
כלומר התואר במקרה כזה הוא יערות ואז או לא משנה אוגד הוא יהיה קשור אליו בקשר קופרה בקיצור קו.
לגבי משפטים שבהם יש כמה פסוקיות אז המבנה ההיררכי משקף את זה?
כן. אז יש לי למשל קטגוריה שנקראת Second כן close קומפלימנטים שאומר שהדבר שאליו היא מחוברת היא פסוקית מושא.
כן, ג'ון SAS is right. אז יש לי he is right שהוא בעצם מנותח בדיוק כמו ג'ון Install.
נכון, רק שבמקום שוויץ יהיה פה. השורש הוא שורש רק של תת העץ.
נכון שהוא עצמו תלוי בסיס על ידי קשר של פסוקית מושא.
בסדר או ג'ון wants to go? אז זה אולי טיפה יותר בעייתי, כי זה כי זה לא ממש משפט שלם בתוך מכונה בתוך משפט אחר, אבל גם לזה יש.
אז יש קטגוריה נפרדת שהם קראו לה xx com עבור מקרים מהסוג הזה.
שאלות עד כאן. אוקיי, אני בעיקר חשוב לי שתקבלו את את התחושה כדי שתוכלו להסתכל על דברים כאלה ולפחות להבין בערך על מה מדובר.
לא מצפה מכם לזכור את כל הדוקומנטרי של יוניברסל דיפנדר, NCIS או אפילו להכיר את כל התופעות האלה לעומק.
אבל כדאי שבכל זאת תהיה לנו שפה משותפת. הדברים האלה חשובים ואני חושב שהם גם חשובים כדי לפתח קצת אינטואיציה לגבי איך פועלת שפה.
The dog that are my home. אוקיי, אז מה זה the dog that my הומור?
אומנם יש בזה פסוקית, אבל הוא עצמו. מה זה הדבר הזה?
הטקסט הזה הוא יחידה תחבירית מסוג.
מר פריס. נכון הוא צירוף שמני. להבדיל, מדדו את מי הוא מארק שהוא מה?
התשובה אם לא the dog at my home.
רק סתם אני רואה כקונטרה שזו פסוקית פשוט.
נכון הוא כן, אבל זה doubt that my name is.
מאיזה סוגו? מספר אחד, שתיים או שלוש?
השני נכון הוא לסוג של השני. מה הגרעין שלו הוא סוג של מה?
כן, הוא סוג של כלב במקרה כלב שאכל את שיעורי הבית שלי, אבל הוא סוג של כלב.
אז הכלב יהיה פה. דוג יהיה רות. ויש לי עוד צלע שבעצם נקראת ACL.
עד שכתבת אלמנט התחלת טיפול close שהוא בעצם מתאר את פסוקית הזיקה הזאת, הוא מסמן שזה פסוקית זיקה דתית, מהירות, סבולת עילאית.
כל זה הזקן או הלינק Close הזה האלה after right.
איתו קשר אז גם יש לי איזשהו מה שבאוניברסיטת NCIS עושים.
זה לוקחים את את הפסוקית מבין השתיים שאין לה דיסק הורס מרכזים לאחד מהם.
יש שאין לה דיס קורס מרקר אין לה את היא לא היא כן, היא לא צמודה או היא לא מתחברת ישירות.
כן למילים כמו after בקלוז אז זהו וכן הלאה.
אלא הפסוקית השנייה נחשבת הפסוקית הראשית והאף right.
כי עניין של קונבנציה יש אולי גם סיבות פולשניות, אבל במידה רבה קניין של קונבנציה זה היא תו כשהוא עכשיו הראשי,
ולכן טו קורות ויש לי עוד צלע מסוג קוראים לזה אדווה בי על קלוז.
כן, לא משנה משהו שמסמן שיש פה עוד פסוקית נוספת שכפופה לה.
אפשרות ראיית המקרים המסובכים עבור דיפרנציאלי זה בעצם נקודות הכשל שלהם.
זה בדרך כלל או אחת מהם. זה הכל. Dynamic כן, הדברים האלה של אמת.
ולמה? כי קרן, קצת קשה בדיוק לומר למה עדיף לנתח כך או אחרת, זה די סימטרי מבחינה תחבירית.
כן, ג'ון אן, מרי גת מארי. אוקיי, לדוגמה, האם אז מה הגרעין?
כן. מה הגרעין של יוסי ודינה התחתנו? כן של יוסי ודינה כן.
האם זה יוסי? האם זה? והאם זה דינה? לא בדיוק ברור.
מה? מה ומה קורה אם יש שלושה כמו לא יודע ג'ון פול ורינגו או משהו כזה או ארבעה.
כן שכחתי את ג'ורג. אז מה קורה שם?
מי? מי מביניהם? אולי זה בכלל? ואולי זה הפסיכים שהם בכלל ההד וורד?
כאילו בעצם אין לטיפה ננסי Structure זה תשובה טובה לזה.
ולכן לפחות כשכתבנו על הנושא הזה מאמר ב 2012 אני חושב שהוא משהו כזה 2009 לא, לא 12 כן, אולי כן משהו כזה.
כן 2011. אז ציטטנו שם מאמר שמראה מספר דו ספרתי של צורות שונות קיימות בעבר פי לפחות בזמנו שהיו בשימוש.
כן, כדי לתאר קודם כי אין כאן שום תשובה באמת מתקבלת על הדעת.
אנחנו פשוט ברגע שאנחנו כפופים לזה שהתפקידים שלנו חייבים להיות מילים ואני לא יכול להוסיף עוד קודקוד,
נגיד מין קודקוד שלא מתאים למילה שאומר אוקיי, כל הדבר הזה הוא צירוף.
אני לא קובע מה Head וואט כי אין לו head word. יש לו איזשהו ניתוח פנימי אחר בדיוק ההנדסי structure לפחות הבסיסיים.
זה לא מתאפשר ולכן צריך לבחור משהו. באוניברסיטת פרנסיס פשוט בחרו את הראשון, אבל זה עניין של קונבנציה.
אוקיי, אז זה ככה מה שרציתי להציג לגבי University Penny זאת על קצה המזלג ואנחנו נראה אותם גם פה בשיעור הבא ובתרגיל הבית.
שאלות. אוקיי, אז עכשיו אולי אתם שואלים את עצמכם קצת דיברנו על זה בתחילת השיעור הקודם,
אבל יכול להיות שרבים מכם שואלים את עצמכם למה אני מלמד אתכם את הדברים בכלל?
כן, מה זה בכלל קשור? אנחנו נלמד. נרשמנו לתואר במדעי המחשב ואנחנו בסוף לומדים לשון.
מה הקטע? ובכן, אז בוא נאמר, זו עמדה לגיטימית, אבל כאמור, אני רוצה שתפתחו קצת אינטואיציה כאן כדי ותבינו את הדברים קצת יותר לעומק.
אבל מעבר לזה גם יש ערך פרקטי לניתוחים לתחביבים האלה וזה משהו.
זה ההערה האחרונה שאני רוצה להגיד בנושא. אז איזה ערך פרקטי יש?
אז למה? אז אני אתן לכם כמה דוגמאות. דוגמה אחת זה זה שבעצם לפעמים הניתוח התחבירי עושה טיסה ביועצי.
כן, הוא בעצם עושה. זה נקרא בעברית הפגת עמימות.
כן, בטח נתקלתם במושג הזה. אז הפגת עמימות?
כלומר ניתן לנתח משהו? צירוף משפט?
טקסט בכמה דרכים. לעיתים המבנה התחבירי קובע אחד לא תמיד אבל לפעמים.
נגיד למשל Fast car, נקניק לכאורה באנגלית.
יכול להיות פה מכונאי של מכוניות מהירות או או בכלל לפעמים את השם הפרטי של מכונאי טוב וכן הלאה.
אה, וכן מכניקה וטעינה של המכונית הנקניק זה גם השם של התחום.
מכניקה לא בקניגסברג. אולי האולי.
אם זה היה ברבים זה היה גם תופס. אבל כאילו מה שהתכוונתי כאן זה אפילו משהו יותר פשוט מזה.
עדיין כל המילים אומרות אותו דבר. אוקיי, פאסט אובר מהיר, מכני, קובר, מכונאי.
אבל או שהוא מכונאי של מכוניות מהירות או שהוא?
בדיוק מכונאי מהיר של מכוניות במקרה אני בטוח בכלל איך?
אז אה אוקיי, אז ככה באמת זה מקרה של כן אוקיי, אז באמת אוקיי, אז זה אולי דוגמה נוספת לזה שלא כל הבעיות היא נפתר על ידי ניתוח תחבירי?
ממש לא. יש עדיין הרבה פעמים מקרים שבהם זה לא נפתר, אבל חלק מהמקרים כן.
בגלל שמסתבר שלשתי הפירושים האלה יש ניתוחים תחביריים שונים.
נכון ואחד מהם, ה fast הוא תלוי בקר נכון?
מה זה הראשון? למה הוא מתאים? אפס תלוי בקר והקר תלוי במקרה זה מתאים לו.
זה בדיוק כאן. המכונית עם המכוניות המהירות, ואם שתיהן תלויות ישירות במכונית אז זה יכול להיות עניין של מכוניות.
בדיוק בדיוק. זה פשוט שני דברים שונים. אז אוקיי, אז לפעמים זה עוזר לעשות דיסה.
אמציה כנל במקרה שראינו בתחילת ההרצאה הזאת בשבוע שעבר.
נכון, לגבי טוק וסאונד אמרנו? שתי המחרוזות האלה מאוד דומות.
כל מה ששונה בהן זה אז מילת יחס אחת יותר גבוהה.
כאן זה טוק תרבות, אם זה הפאונד שהוא ההאנגר ואם בהאנגר.
אבל ברור שיש כאן הבדל סמנטי יותר עמוק.
ובאמת הוא משתקף במבנה התלויות, כי באחד מהם האנגר או תת העץ של תודה האנגר.
נכון, יהיה תת עץ שכפוף לטרוק.
נכון, זה הפירוש. הפירוש העליון זה פירוש שמה.
שבעצם מתייחס לזה שהם לקחו אל. נכון שהם לקחו אל.
איפשהו, וכאן זה מקרה שהם מצאו בו ולכן זה קשור לפה.
אז המבנה התחבירי? מבחין לי בין הדברים האלה שמבחינת string.
ומבחינת part of speech כאילו הם בעצם נורא דומים.
נכון גם במילים, גם ברצף הפרטי speech. הכל מאוד מאוד דומה, אבל ברור שיש כאן הבדל משמעותי והוא משתקף בתחביר.
כן, הרבה פעמים גם אנחנו יכולים מהמבנה התחבירי גם לקבל איזשהו proxy.
כלומר Proxy הוא לא בדיוק באופן ישיר, מתאר את הסמנטיקה ונותן לנו רמז די טוב עד כדי כך שהרבה פעמים לפחות שיטות בוא נאמר גם שיטות יותר קלאסיות וגם שיטות.
אם אתם רוצים לעשות משהו מהיר, כן, זאת אומרת, אתם מוצאים משהו שפועל על הרבה מאוד Data מאוד מהר.
אז אתם הרבה פעמים תשתמשו בניתוח תחבירי שסך הכל אפשר לעשות אותו ביעילות מאוד גבוהה ביחס לא
יודע מה להפעיל עליהם על הטקסט פעולות הרבה יותר כבדות וזה יתן לכם כבר איזשהו מידע תחבירי.
אז נגיד למשל, אם נתקלתם במידע סמנטי, סליחה על היחסים שמובאים בטקסט.
אז אם יש לכם נגיד Birds, אני רואה Submit את סנט ראונד Back ופאבל.
כן, מטאקסס כן. אז כבר מהמבנה התחבירי אתם יכולים לראות שמדובר כאן ב BLS.
שמיטת בייס מתואר נכון? כאילו אז זה כבר יחס אחד שאתם יכולים לומר.
יש כאן סנטור שהגיש הצעות חוק?
כן, אתם יכולים. אתם יכולים לראות שהפיל זה נוגעים לאינטגרל הישן כי יש קשר תחבירי ביניהם.
אתם יכולים לראות שבגלל שהסם שעשה המטוס הזה הוא בעצם חלק מצירוף סנטור בראון בק בעצם הוא חלק משם יותר ארוך.
כן, אתם קוראים לזה flat, וגם אתם יכולים לדעת שהסנטר בראון וכזה הוא Republic מקנזס, ושהרבה מכם כן זה מתייחס פרסם את הר ברוקבק.
והסיבה לזה היא לא. בעיקר שיש פה פסיק, כי לפעמים פסיקים הם פנייה למישהו נכון, או שלפעמים פסיקים הם התחלה של משפט חדש או לפעמים פסיקים הם כל מיני דברים.
אבל. אבל מרגע שהמבנה התחבירי אמר לכם זה הוא.
תראו Republic info כן, זה עשו תמורה של סנט רובם back.
כן זה מה שנקרא הפוזיציה. אז זה אומר שהדבר הזה התיאור הזה מתייחס אליו?
כן, זה איזשהו תיאור שהתיאור שלו, של היישות שמתארת את זה.
סנאטור בראון אז מין קוי קנדי וויליאם אקסטרה Action.
אם זה מה שאתם מחפשים, בהחלט מבנה תחבירי הוא אופציה טובה, ואם אתם רוצים לעשות משהו מאוד מהר, זה יכול להיות שזה הפתרון שתבחרו?
כן. אז כאמור, זה כן סמנטי במובן הזה או יחסים במובן הזה שזה עוזר לענות על שאלות כמו מה הוגש מרגיש, מה הוא או מי הוא סנטור בראון Back?
למה לקבל כן חוק קנזס. מי זה הרפובליקני פה מקנזס?
שם התואר וכן כן טרוריסטים כן לא ירוץ בראש רץ כמה פעמים הוא ירוץ כמה שנים?
אה, לא סימנתי פה. בעצם אתה רואה שתוק, אין תגובה.
זה באותו אופן לא? בכל מקרה תוכו הוא רהוט כי אתה רואה שהוא הקודקוד היחיד שלא נכנסת אליו.
קשת באמת הייתי צריך לסמן את זה יותר ברור.
אולי להוסיף עוד צלע כמו שעשיתי כאן. לפעמים עושים את זה ולפעמים לא.
אז כאילו אם אתה רוצה להדגיש מהשורש אז אתה מן מוסיף דמוי node כזה של רות.
כן, אבל בגדול יש קודקוד אחד או יש מילה אחת שאין הצלע נכנסת והיא בשורש בסדר.
כן, נניח בשפה שלנו שזה באמת פרוקסי.
יותר קלה מאשר רשימה של תאגידים. אה נכון, אז אנחנו נצטרך לדון בזה ואנחנו נדון בזה בהמשך.
נדון בזה בשבוע הבא. כן, בשבוע הבא כבר נגיע לזה.
אנחנו נראה שיש דרכים יעילות לקבל ניתוח תחבירי, אבל אינטואיטיבית אני חושב שאפשר אולי להשתכנע בזה שהרבה פעמים זה יותר פשוט,
והסיבה לזה היא שהתחביב הוא בסך הכל אני אומר ככה בהכללה גסה, אבל בסך הכל יש לו מבנה די נוקשה.
כן, כלומר התחביר זה מין אוסף של כללים שניתן לתאר אותם.
ושוב אני אומר את הכל ביחס. הסמנטיקה ניתנים לתיאור קומפקטי הרבה יותר מאשר סמנטיקה,
ולכן סך הכל אתה צריך באיזשהו מובן אינטואיטיבי פחות ידע או לייצג פחות דברים כדי להבין אותו, מאשר כדי ממש להבין מה המשפט הזה אומר.
כן. ואפשר גם לראות את זה הרבה פעמים שבעצם אם אתה דובר של איזושהי שפה, אתה יכול להבין בערך מה המבנה התחבירי של גם לא נגמרת פה ושם.
תתאר, לא, זה לא יהיה מושלם, אבל יהיה לך איזושהי תמונה הרבה פעמים לא רעה לגבי מה המבנה של המשפט, גם בלי שאתה בדיוק מבין אותו.
כי למה? כי אולי מליות מלהיות דקדוקיות.
כן Function words. אתה כן תבין. כן, סך הכל כמה יש כבר בשפה.
יש מספר לא גדול לפחות של מרכזיות.
נכון, הם מיידעים כינויים, רומזים, כינויי גוף, סימוני מילות יחס וכן הלאה וכן הלאה וכן הלאה.
אז זה כבר ייתן לך עוגנים. ואם לשפה יש סדר מילים מסוים, מה שברוב השפות יש סדר מילים טיפוסי, אז גם את זה תבין,
ואז אולי תוכל לנחש בצורה מושכלת מי הנושא ומי המושא ומי וכן הלאה וכן הלאה.
אז כאילו ואם היא על השפה יש נטיות מה שנקרא מופלא גנטי עתיד.
דיברנו על זה. אז גם אם לא תדע מה אומר פה השורש הזה, תגיד אה, זה כנראה מתייחס לפועל בגוף שלישי רבים.
עתיד מתברר כן, ואתה כבר תדע די הרבה.
בעצם, בלי לדעת יותר מדי על הסמנטיקה, בעוד שעכשיו, מה זה אומר?
הסמנטיקה סמנטיקה זה מושג מאוד רחב. כפי שאנחנו עוד מעט נדבר עליו.
נתחיל לדבר עליו ככה יראה ממש תכף יותר בפרוטרוט.
אבל באופן עקרוני אין אין. זאת אומרת, אנחנו לא מתקרבים אפילו למודל טוב.
למה זה סמנטיקה? ואם תשים לב,
הדרך שבה בעצם הייתה פריצת דרך בתחום הזה זה פשוט לקחת כמויות פנטסטיות של דאטה ולאמן אותם על דברים סופר כבדים שאף אחד לא מבין בדיוק איך הם פועלים.
וזה הפרוקסי כאילו הכי טוב שיש לנו.
אז ניסו שוב. ניסיתי להעביר לך אינטואיציה, אבל אנחנו נמשיך לדון בדברים האלה.
למה? הרבה פעמים כדי לעשות משימות סמנטית אתה מפעיל משהו שלא יודע.
יש בו 100 מיליארד פרמטרים ועושה טריליון. אתה יודע, Float thing point operations.
וכדי לעשות ניתוח תחבירי גם אתה מפעיל משהו לא נורא קל עדיין הרבה הרבה יותר פשוט בסדר.
עוד שאלות. בסדר, אז נעבור לנושא הבא שבו באמת נתחיל לעסוק בסמנטיקה.
שזה write in בסמנטיקה מסוימת מאוד, מה שנקרא סמנטיקה הלקסיקון.
כן. אז אנחנו נדון ב Wedding בלאנס הספציפית ב Non קונטקסט שעולה.
זאת אומרת זה עם זה ואני אסביר ככה לקראת סוף השיעור. מה זה אומר על פרויקט טקסטואלי, אבל הוא הדבר INS, כלומר ייצוגים, וקטורים של מילים.
אז קצת נגענו בהם, אבל עכשיו אנחנו נדבר קצת יותר לעומק ובעצם נקודת המוצא של הדיון הזה.
אתם יודעים מה? אולי שאלה מקדימה. כמה מכם יצא לכם לצלם לשמוע על המושג הזה של הביטלס?
אוקיי, מאיזה הקשרים שמעתם עליהם? עזוב אותך פשוט ובאיזה מועדים, בין אם אתה משתמש.
גם את. אוקיי, אחלה עוד איזה קשרים שיצא לכם.
אז בעיקר דברים שלי Information אני כבר באמת.
כן. אוקיי. אז אוקיי, טכנולוגיה סופר פופולרית.
חלקכם כבר מכירים אותה. בכל מקרה, אני אתחיל מההתחלה גם לטובת אלה שלא שלא שמעו עליהם.
אז נקודת המוצא שלנו זה מה שנקרא הרבה פעמים עד היסוד.
ישנה סכנה היפותזה קומוטטיבית היפותזה ההתפלגות תתפוצץ סופית שבגדול מה שהיא
אומרת כן זה שמילים שמשתמשים בהם באותם הקשרים או מילים שמופיעות באותם ההקשרים,
נוטות לכך שיהיה להם משמעות דומה.
אוקיי, עכשיו מבחינת אם תשימו לב המשפט הזה בעצם זה אוצר עבור כן עבור אנשי NLP, כי ככל שההתקפה התזה הזאת היא נכונה, וככל שנוכל לתת משמעות טכנית,
כן, סטטיסטית למושג קונטקסט כן, אם נצליח איכשהו לפרמיה לא או כן או לעולם קונטקסט כן הקשר באיזושהי צורה שאנחנו יכולים בקלות לחשב.
ההיפותזה הזאת נותנת לנו גשר בין התפלגות התפלגות ההקשרים שבהם מילה מופיעה.
כן, מושג שלפחות כפי שאנחנו תכף נראה, תרגום שלו הוא תרגום מאוד טכני לבין מושג הרבה יותר ערטילאי ובלתי נגיש לכאורה, שהוא המשמעות של מילים.
אוקיי, אז זה דבר נחמד, כי כי בעצם מבחינת עברית יש כאן לנו הזדמנות לבצע איזושהי פעולה סטטיסטית מכני של ספירה,
של משהו שמחשבים יודעים לעשות היטב ובעזרת זה לקבל איזשהו Proxy.
איזשהו רמז כן, איזשהו ייצוג למשמעויות של מילים שלא ממש ברור איך אחרת אפשר לייצג אותם.
זאת אומרת מילון ללכת ולקחת מילון ולנסות לקודד אותו.
אולי זה אפשרי, אבל מילונים הם תמיד חלקיים.
הם לא כוללים את כל המובנים. הם לא כוללים את כל המילים, הם לא מתעדכנים, הם לא קיימים באותה איכות ובאותו היקף, בכל השפות ובכל הדומיין.
אוקיי, אז יש כאן הזדמנות גדולה. אז כן, אז הרעיון של סמנטיקה פרובוקטיבית או של בדימוס?
כן, בדיוק. זה בעצם איזשהו סוג של הרעיון הזה, של סמנטיקה די סטנדרטי בבית.
זה בעצם שאנחנו רוצים לייצג מילים. התפלגות על פני ההקשרים שבהם הם שבהם.
המילים מופיעות עכשיו לכיוון הזה, שמקורותיו עוד אצל זליג האריס,
הבלשן הידוע בשנות החמישים והעבודות של ויטגנשטיין לגבי כן לגבי המשמעות של מילה כתבנית השימוש שבה בעצם שאר שהמילים מקבלות את משמעותן על ידי האופן.
שבו הם כן, שבו הם משתמשים בהם, שבו הדוברים עושים בהם שימוש.
אז אנחנו לא נפרט על זה יותר מדי, ורק לומר שיש כאן בהחלט יסודות תאורטיים עמוקים,
שמגיעים לא רק בתחום הבלשנות ופילוסופיה של השפה, אלא גם בתחום של מדעי הקוגניציה שעסקו למשל.
מי שמעניין אותו מוזמן לקרוא את המאמר מ 2001 כאן,
שמצוטט של מקדונלד ורמז סקר שבעצם ניסו לבחון את השאלה האם גם בני אדם רגישים להקשרים השונים שבהם מילים מופיעות,
והאם הם מפרשים אותם על בסיס תבניות או על בסיס ההתפלגות של התפוצה שבה הם מופיעים בסך הכל עם מסקנות חיוביות?
אוקיי, אז זה ככה ברמת המוטיבציה הכללית.
בואו עכשיו נהפוך את זה למשהו יותר קונקרטי.
אז אמרנו שאנחנו רוצים לייצג מילה, כי התפלגות על פני הקשר התפלגות.
אנחנו יודעים מה זה, אבל מה זה הקשרים? אז דרך אחת פשוטה להגיד בעצם להגדיר הקשר בצורה מכנית זה פשוט המילים האחרות או החלק בטקסט שבו המילה הזאת מופיעה.
החלקים בטקסט שבה המילה הזאת מופיעה עכשיו. מה זה החלקים בטקסט?
נגיד, למשל המילים האחרות שמופיעות עם המילה הזאת באותו משפט?
אוקיי, תחת הרעיון הזה אנחנו בעצם חושבים על כל מילה שמופיעה, כל מילה, כל טקסט.
כן, כל מילה היא נחשבת לקונטקסט. ועכשיו אם אני רוצה להסתכל על איזושהי מילה ולייצג את התפלגות ההקשרים שלה, מה שכל מה שאני צריך לעשות זה בעצם להסתכל.
איזה מילים היא נוטה להופיע באותו המשפט? אוקיי, אז אני לוקח קורפוס גדול של טקסט.
נגיד אני רוצה לייצג את המילה אמבטיה בהפתעה, בנפח קורפוס גדול, גדול, גדול של טקסט.
כמה גדול שאני אצליח למצוא. מחפש את כל המופעים של המילה בכתב, מזהה את המשפטים שבהם המילים המופעים האלה מופיעים.
ומסתכל על הראיות שיש שם וזאת התפוצה.
אלה הקשרים. ספציפית. תכף אני הופך את זה לווקטור.
הצורה הכי פשוטה זה פשוט להגיד בגבוה. אז כן, פרופורציה.
למה לא? נכון, זה בדרך כלל הצורה הכי פשוטה שאפשר כן לייצג בה, לייצג בטקסט או לייצג במשפט.
אז אני מסתכל ורואה כמה פעמים מופיעה המילה זה בתוך אותו משפט עם המילה כמעט ו ואין ואין ולייקר
water ובואו וסטים וקוד פאדי ובסיס קורא וכן הלאה וכן הלאה ופשוט שנייה אחת והוא לי רשימה ארוכה,
ארוכה ארוכה. אלה הסטטיסטים שלי מהקורפוס אוקיי, זה בעצם ההתפלגות האמפירית של ההופעות של המילה, בטח בקורפוס שלי.
כן? את השאלה קודם. ביחד עם זה אתה.
מדהים כאילו. זה כואב ולהסיק מזה.
אוקיי, אז שאלה מצוינת. אנחנו נדבר עליה. אנחנו בדיוק נדבר עליה.
אבל קודם קצת כן, אז זה מיד אנחנו.
מיד נדבר על החסרונות בגישה הזאת, אבל לפחות באופן בסיסי, מה שאני רוצה זה פשוט לייצג את ההתפלגות הזאת, כן לייצג או את ההתפלגות שממנה נדגם הווקטור הזה.
אם לדייק, נכון? כי בעצם אני מניח שזה איזשהו דוגמה.
כן, איזשהו Sample איזשהו מדגם מתוך ההתפלגות של שפה שבעזרתה שערכתי את ההתפלגות האמפירית הזאת.
אבל בסופו של דבר אני אנסה למצוא את הגדולה עם Distribution.
אז אוקיי, אבל לפחות ברמה הכי פשוטה, או שאני פשוט אני משערת אותה להיות ההתפלגות האמפירית.
ואז מה שאני מקבל זה וקטור במימד שהוא כמו גודל אוצר המילים.
נכון כי גודל אוצר המילים שבכל קואורדינטות בו רשום כל קואורדינטות המתאימה לאיזושהי מילה ובעצם הערך של הקואורדינטות זה מספר הפעמים,
מספר ההופעות המשותפות. מה שנקרא COCO Francis של של המילה שאותה אני מייצג במקרה הזה אמבטיה עם המילה שזה הקואורדינטות שלה.
אוקיי. מה הדבר?
איך הדבר הזה יכול לעזור לי? אז למשל אם אני מניח את ההיפותזה ההתפלגות, אז דרך אחת לנסח אותה באופן טכני זה כן.
זה בעצם להגיד שמה שאמרנו קודם נכון.
דמיון בין ההתפלגויות אומר דמיון בין הגוונים, נכון?
אז אוקיי, אז מה זה דמיון בין ההתפלגויות? נגדיר איזה שהיא מטריקה פשוט על הפקטורים האלה, נגיד מטריקה פופולרית.
זה הכל סמלי, מתאים מה שנקרא פשוט כן קוסינוס הזווית בין הווקטורים.
כן, פשוט מכפלה סקלרית בין הווקטורים חלקי מכפלת הנורמות.
כן, משהו שאני מעריך ראיתם באלגברה לינארית נכון?
אתה עדיין באזור בנימין? כן. אוקיי. כן, אז שזה מספר שמקבל ערכים בין מה למה?
מינוס אחד לאחד, מינוס אחד לאחד. במקרה שלנו אתם צודקים שבגלל שהכורדים נטיות הם אי שליליות אז זה יהיה מספר בין אפס לאחד.
מספר בין אפס לאחד במקרה שלנו או באופן שלילי בין מינוס אחד לאחד, כשאחד מצביע על דמיון מקסימלי ואפס או מינוס אחד תלוי בהקשר מצביע על דמיון מינימאלי.
אוקיי. ועכשיו יש לנו כאן על פניו כלי מאוד חזק.
אם באמת ההיפותזה הזאת היפותזות, זאת אומרת אני מייצג כל מילה בתור איזשהו וקטור.
כן, זה כמובן עשיתי פה משהו כאילו מן הטלה של זה על תלת מימד רק בשביל הדיאגרמה, כי אני לא יודע לשרטט וקטורים ב50 אלף או 100 אלף מימדים,
אז כל אחת מהמילים קיבלה איזשהו וקטור שמבוסס על הקואורדינטות שמבוססות על על התפוצה, על המילים שאיתם היא מופיעה.
כן מופיעה הופעות משותפות על ההתפלגות, ההופעות המשותפות של המילה הזאת.
במילים אחרות ואז לכל מילה יש לי וקטור כזה לניוז Papers.
בווקטור אחד ומגזין יש וקטור שני ויקינג, וקטור שלישי וכן הלאה וכן הלאה.
ואני מקווה כן, אם עשיתי את הכל כמו שצריך.
שנייה אחת שהיחס הסמנטי של הדמיון היותר קרוב בין מגזין ומינוס Paper לעומת מגזין או נגיד מגזין בביקיני השתקף גם בכוס,
היא מקסימלית, היא יותר גבוהה בין מגזין לניוז Paper מאשר בין מגזין לפאנק.
אוקיי, אז זה הפרו גם כן. אם אתם חושבים שבדבר הזה יש חורים, יש בו.
כן, מיד נגיע לזה.
אבל כאילו אני אומר מבחינת זה הכיוון כן לייצג מילים בתור וקטורים על סמך בגופו את הסטטיסטיקות שלהם הווקטורים האלה לבדוק את רמת הדמיון ביניהם.
ואם עשינו את הכל כמו שצריך והיא היפותזה וספורטיבית נכונה לקבל שבאמת הדמיון הסמנטי מתאים לדמיון.
עד אוקיי, הדמיון הווקטורי והדמיון הסמנטי איכשהו נותנים פרדי קציצות דומות.
אבל הבעיה היא או אחת. יש כאן כמה בעיות, אבל אחת הם שכן נחנו בגדול.
השיטה הזאת שכתובה כאן היא כבר לא השיטה הפופולרית כיום במופע הזה שלה, ויש לזה כל מיני סיבות.
אחת מהם אתה באמת ציינת שהרבה פעמים אנחנו לא.
אנחנו לא רוצים לתת כל כך הרבה משקל למיליציות שמופיעות בהרבה הקשרים שונים.
אנחנו איך שרוצים להנחית קצת את הסיגנל שלהם, כי זה לא נורא אינפורמטיבי שמילה זה או and in וכן הלאה.
אם זה אז יש כל מיני שיטות להחליק את זה או להנחית את הכן להנחית את הסגנון שמגיע
מהמילים ה function words ולהגדיר את אלה שהמילים היותר סימטריות אבל יש כאן.
אז זה דבר אחד הסיבה, אבל שלא נדון בה יותר מדי לעומק זה כי יש כאן עוד סיבה שיהיה קצת יותר קשה לתקן.
והיא הסיבה שבעצם עברו מהשיטות מבוססות ספירה לשיטות אחרות שתכף נגדיר.
וזה שבעצם המימדים כן הם לא בדיוק המימדים שאותם המימדים בשיטה מבוססי ספירה הם לא בדיוק המימדים שאותם היינו רוצים.
כן, אז מה הרעיון? אז אמרנו תראו, אנחנו רוצים להגדיר מילה כי ההתפלגות על פני הקשרים.
כן, סוגי קשרים, משהו כזה. אבל מה זה הקשר?
הקשר זה מילה קצת ערטילאית. כן? מה זה בדיוק אומר הקשר? אז אמרנו טוב, הקשרים אנחנו לא בדיוק יודעים מה זה.
לעומת זאת לספור מילים אנחנו כן יודעים. אז בוא נגיד שזה פשוט המילה מילים שמופיעות איתה באותו משפט בחלון של פלוס מינוס.
כי מילים לא משנה. אבל מה בעצם פספסנו במהלך הזה?
שבעצם? זה בעצם לא רמת התיאור הנכונה.
היינו מעדיפים שה הפיצ'רים שלנו יהיו פיצ'רים שבאיזשהו מובן הם פיצ'רים שבערך קולעים פיצ'ר קצת יותר אבסטרקטי.
בוא נאמר ככה למשל, זה של מילה מסויימת מופיעה עם הרבה מגזין והשניה מופיעה הרבה פעמים עם ניוז Paper.
כן, או שמילה אחת מופיעה הרבה פעמים עם בגין והשנייה הרבה פעמים עם Start.
זה לא אמור נורא לשנות. כן, זה לא אמור נורא לשנות כי בעצם מילה זה זה קצת כבוד.
כן, זה קצת גס להגיד שההקשר נקבע על פי מילה. אם הייתם אומרים.
המילה הזאת מופיעה בהקשרים. או להיות או בהקשרי עיתונות, או בהקשרי אופניים וכן הלאה ותחת ההכשרה אופניים הייתם כוללים גם ויקינג וגם אני לא יודע מה.
אני לא כל כך בקיא בטרמינולוגיה של אופניים, אבל איך נקרא היפודרום?
לא היפודרום זה עם סוסים. חישוק ורמה כידון ולא יודע כל מיני מושגים של אופניים.
אז הייתם אומרים אוקיי, זה נשמע לי כמו הגדרה מתקבלת על הדעת לסוג של קשר.
ובאמת חשוב ידע, אבל מילה זה יותר מדי גס.
כן, זה פחות מדי אבסטרקטי, יותר מדי קונקרטי. היינו רוצים לעבור בפיצ'רים שהם קצת יותר מתוחכמים, שהם איכשהו פיצ'רים יותר אבסטרקטיים, יותר סמנטי.
אוקיי, אז זמן להפסקה אנחנו עושים טיול קטן עכשיו לפרדס הרחוק.
ברנט מצא בשלוש ארבע שלוש. זה הבניין החדש הזה, שמר על בטיחות.
אוקיי, אז נתראה שם. זה טוב, זה קבוע נגד זה.
הרבה מאוד צדדים. יש לך מקלדת?
אז זה בדיוק מה שאנחנו מבינים עכשיו. מגיע לאורי כתב את זה.
זה בעיה שמישהו מנהל את כל הכתובים. סגרנו עליך.
אתה צודק, אני דיברתי בעיקר. הבעיה שזה לא באמת האסטרטגיה הנכונה ובעצם דרך אחרת.
עכשיו כל הבעיה הזאת של בעיות שאתה עושה במצב כזה לא היה את האסטרטגיה הנוכחית.
יש לי. את צודקת, לא כל כך חבל על זה, אבל זה לגבי.
אפשר לומר עכשיו מדברים על בתי גלגלים.
פלסטי באף. זה סרטן ברמה כזאת שלא אכפת לו מה שפחות בסדר.
איפה נשמע?